Drive by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
But you have a responsibility of greatness.
There's this very few people that ever get to the position that you,
not just,
we're in when you won the title,
when you were the youngest ever UFC heavyweight where light heavyweight
champion,
not just that,
the youngest ever UFC champion.
Now,
not just that there's that,
there's also responsibility that comes with potential.
It's not,
it's not just what,
what you've done and you know,
it's what you could've done.
Right.
You,
you fought Alexander Gustafson.
Be honest about that.
How much did you train for that fight?
I trained,
I trained for the fight,
but,
but I,
uh,
I definitely,
I had this thing where I just felt invincible and,
uh,
did a lot of wild stuff leading up to the fight.
I definitely didn't give it my all
as far as partying and sleeping.
Right.
Stay up all night.
Yeah.
I mean,
when you win a fight like that where you weren't 100%,
does that sort of almost reinforced this idea that you could do anything you
want?
And then man,
imagine if I trained next time,
if it's someone big,
I'll train.
Yeah.
So I have this,
I'm going to share something with,
I'm not sure if I've ever shared this with anyone else before,
but I had this crazy thing that I would do,
um,
where I would party one week before every fight.
And I did it throughout my whole career.
And uh,
and this was stupid,
but it was this mental crutch that I had.
I literally would one week before every flight I would go out and I will get
blacked out wasted.
And my logic was if this guy were to beat me somehow,
um,
I had,
I can look myself in the mirror and say that,
well,
I lost because I got hammered the week before the fight.
So,
so it was a built in safety net.
It was a safety net.
Yeah,
exactly.
So I did it my whole career.
I would go out and get hammered when we,
before every fight.
Have you ever worked with a sports psychologist?
No,
but now,
but now I don't.
My,
my open st proof.
I was the first fight that I did not do that.
It was my
worst for apartments.
So I don't think it was your worst performance.
I think you were very unjustly criticized for that fight.
Cause I think over in St Pru is a very tough guy.
He's a very difficult fired.
He's very strong.
He's got a brutal left kick.
He's athletic,
he moves well.
I believe it was a good performance,
but it was my worst performance.
See I think OVN St proves of really tough guy and he was a tough fight.
And you hadn't fought in a long time.
You were off for how long?
How many months?
16 months or something,
Huh?
Yeah,
it was done.
It was over a year.
Yeah,
it was a long time.
Over a year.
You're fighting a guy who had been pretty active and fought some good guys,
had a great victory of a Shogun and looked real good and a lot of his fights.
And was an up and comer
main thing about events that really bothered me.
It was um,
he was,
he was the most,
um,
well he was seizing.
Hey,
actually it has been fighting longer than I have.
A lot of people don't realize that,
but he was just so,
um,
green and raw still like a skill wise,
skill wise.
Like I,
I don't,
um,
I study everybody extensively and then I come up with their patterns.
Um,
I've figured out the way they flinch.
I figured out their first favorite punch,
their second favorite punch,
that third,
their favorite combinations,
the way they're set up.
So they take downs when they clinch.
What side of the head is going to be literally everything.
I know everything about every opponent,
what side they're going to shoot,
whether it's going to be a head inside his head outside.
What am I going to do about that?
You know,
I figured out everything,
why they shoot,
where,
what area of the cage they like to shoot everything.
Um,
and uh,
with all the same proof.
He,
he,
he doesn't know what he's going to do.
He's so,
um,
I don't know,
Orthodox and Orthodox,
um,
you know,
he gets these random knock offs from these weird angles and he's just wing stuff
and he almost closes his eyes and next thing you know,
he's knocked somebody out,
you know.
So the scary thing about him was he's so unpredictable,
uh,
and so,
and I had a lot on the line.
Um,
so I just said,
you know what,
this guy is a,
he's in a shell pretty much the whole fight.
He was defensive the whole site and a,
and I just thought I close through the fight,
um,
and not really risk anything,
which I felt like I let myself down because I'm normally,
I would just,
I mean normally when you get someone like that,
you just,
you know,
take them out.
You know,
you should,
I should have just been able to take them out.
But I was content with a winning and I think that was,
I think that was one of the first fights where I actually just wanted to get the
win,
get my money,
go back to,
uh,
what are my actual goal,
which was DC.
Um,
instead of,
um,
wanting to finish this guy like normal.
So I had to really question my,
yeah,
I really questioned myself and why,
um,
why I was like that,
why I was consulting with closely.
Yeah.